خطوات قليله فقط امام بدء الاستحقاق
الانتخابي في تركيا بشكل رسمي الرئيس
التركي رجب طيب اردوغان اكد ان حزبه يدرس
امكانيه تقديم موعد الانتخابات دون الذهاب
الى انتخابات مبكرا على حد قوله
جديد وانتم افضل من يعرف اهميه الانتخابات
2003 التي ربما نجريها في وقت مبكر قليلا
بعد مراعاه الظروف الموسميه
اثناء اجتماع ما بات يعرف بالطاوله
السداسيه وهو تحالف سته احزاب معارضه
يحاول تنسيق الجهود للفوز بالانتخابات
القادمه لكن خلافات حول اختيار مرشح مشترك
يمثل المعارضه في الانتخابات الرئاسيه
المقبله باتت تقلق الشارع المعارض لا سيما
ان اكبر حزبين في الطاوله السداسيه بعيدان
كل البعد عن التوافق على هويه المرشح
كمال
اجلو زعيمه حزب الشعب الجمهوري هو من
سيكون مرشح مشتركا للمعارضه ما لم تعترض
هذا الترشيح عوائق او استطلاعات راييين
تعطي شخص اخر الافضليه خصوصا بعد القرار
القضائي بحق اكرم اوغلو الذي استبعد من
المنافسه
رئيس بلديه اسطنبول اكرم امام بلو في
الفوز بالانتخابات اكبر من حدودك ملك
الجدار اوغلو زعيم حزب الشعب الجمهوري
المثقل بعداء شريحه من المحافظين بسبب
مواقفه السابقه من قضايا عديده كانت تمسهم
بشكل اساسي خلال العقدين الماضي
سته يريدون الترشح للرئاسه لكن الاكثر حظا
كمال كلتش دار اوغلو رئيس حزب الشعبي
الجمهوري الذي اسس هذه الطاوله وضمن
استمرارها حتى اليوم لكن ميرال اكتشنر لا
تريده مرشحا لرئاسه الجمهوريه المعارضه
التركيه تعاهدت في حال وصولها الى السلطه
باعاده العمل في النظام البرلماني مع
تقييد كبير لصلاحيات رئيس الجمهوريه
والغاء النظام الرئاسي المعمول به حاليا
ومنح استقلاليه للقضاء وعدم تقييد الحريات
العامه المرشح والمشترك للمعارضه لا يبدو
انه هويته ستظهر خلال المدى المنظور
فحالته الشرخ في الطاوله السداسيه وان
حاول الزعماء واخفائها لكنها كواليس غير
بعيده عن العدسات ولا شك ان توافق زعماء
المعارضه على مرشح وحيد هو اهم استحقاق
لهم خلال الانتخابات المرتقبه زيدان زينجو
العربيه اسطنبول